good evening ladies and gentlemen
members of the council
welcome to this evening Southeastern
area planning committee
um
two notices the first is the recording
of the meeting please note the council
will be recording and Publishing on the
council's website any part of this
meeting held in Open Session
and fire in the event of a fire officers
will notify those present and please use
the fire exits marked with a green
running man which is just fade out the
end and out the door the fire assembly
pointed sparked his bank car park please
gather there and await further
instruction
uh gender item two apologies for absence
I believe we've got four apologies
counselor
Bill councilor Boyce councilor Helm and
councilor schemes I think apart from
that we're all present
[Music]
oh yes chairman apart from that everyone
else is here thank you
[Music]
most members are probably aware that
there's been he's Poland in hospital but
obviously members of the public may not
so we all wish him all the the best and
hopefully see him soon
uh gender item
three minutes of the last meeting to
confirm the minutes that a meeting of
the committee held on the 17th of August
of this year
um I think most members will be aware
that we had problems with the sound
recording there was um
apparently a microphone that was playing
up and causing a lot of distortion on
the recording it um appeared at one
stage that I said something that I would
not have said and uh
that showed up on the recording that
nobody apparently heard it and also I
believe
um
the committee Services thought that he
made criticisms of them which as far as
I'm aware we certainly did not in the
uh urgent items but apart from that
anybody got any questions on the
on the minutes if not do you all agree
them
thank you
uh gender items for disclosure of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph line and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting and
while I'm speaking I will declare
um I believe it's a pecuniary interest
for a gender item five
at Tinkers hole as the applicant is a
one of my customers and I will leave the
room for that item anybody else got any
cancer Miss hole
five anybody else
okay in that case we will move on to the
gender item five and I will ask the vice
chairman to
share this one for me and uh we'll be
back later hopefully
[Music]
we've got one speaker
all right but we're still going yeah
[Music]
good evening everybody for the benefit
of the tape and for those listening at
home
um my name is councilor Adrian fluke and
I'm the ward member for South Minster
and the vice chairman of this committee
um can I ask anybody that speaks this
evening to try and speak up and speak
clearly because we are having problems
with the streaming so we're now going to
consider planning application 2200
two six eight four which is a gender
item five and appears on page 13 of your
agenda
um the officer presenting I don't know
thank you very much Miss Dungey over to
you
well
I need mine have you got one there
could you pass
[Music]
that might be the problem
[Music]
Cannon
planning permission is sort of the
erection of a show home and sales and
marketing Suite Associated car park and
hard on top landscaping in connection
with the adjacent Burnham Waters retire
Retirement Community Development
the Tempe permission sort is for one
year only and at the end of the 12-month
period or further to the completion of
the original sales and marketing Suite
on the main development site whichever
is sooner the change of useful cease and
the land will be returned back to its
earlier condition
as per the members update sent around
three new ecology conditions have been
added to the recommendation and by way
of a verbal update to members it has
come to the attention of officers that
some planning history at the site has
not been included within the committee
report
this planning history relates to several
applications which were refused for the
use of the land to the rear of the
application site for the stationing of a
residential Caravan to accommodate a
security officer for a temporary period
of three years
these applications relate to the
agricultural use of carbuncle farm and
do not relate to this application in
question
this is the application site
the site is located to the north of
Malden Road and to the west of tinker's
hole
[Music]
Northwest of the settlement boundary of
Burnham Crouch
the site forms part of Uncle farm and is
formed of rough made ground and a
trackway the site has been approved as
the temporary construction compound for
the adjacent development known as
Burnham Waters
and this was approved under a discharge
of conditions application in 2021
[Music]
this is the block plan showing the
setback location of the show home and
marketing Suite as well as the formation
of the car park to the front of the
building as well as other Landscaping
and hard standing
[Music]
this
is the sorry this is not the updated
presentation
um these are the proposed elevations and
floor plan
[Music]
this is the proposed Street Scene
and uh these are photographs showing the
site taken from Tinkers Hall
um this is the existing site office on
the construction compound which will be
converted into the show home and sales
Suite
temporary planned Commissioners sought
for the erection of the show home I went
to a delay in the signing of the section
278 agreement relating to phase one of
the adjacent Retirement Community
um and called 3.1 of the section 106
agreement associated with the scheme the
delay in the signing of the agreement
has delayed construction and has
prevented the construction of the show
home on the original site
the applicant therefore intends to erect
the temporary show home to facilitate
the early sales of the market units and
permit occupation as soon as possible
after the release of the affordable
units
The Prompt occupation of the units will
assist in addressing market and
affordable housing and supply issues in
the district
owing to the public benefits that will
arise as a result of the development and
the fact that the permission source is
temporary and the learner will be
restored to its original use and state
at the end of the period any potential
temporary harm is considered to be
overcome and mitigated
The Proposal already has been approved
as a temporary site compound for the
development and with regard to design
neighbor amenity and ecology the
development is considered to be
acceptable
The Proposal is therefore recommended
for approval subject to the conditions
included in the report
okay thank you very much Miss Duncan
um I understand that there's an objector
um Joe Coombs who wishes to speak
oh right okay well if you'd like to come
forward
um if you'd like to sit with that
microphone is and
um once you're comfortable
um you've got a you've got a total of
two minutes to speak and uh if you can
start speaking when when the clock's up
we're just waiting for the clock
to be doing
yeah thank you
um
to planning application which I think
contradicts both the word
I think there are lots of policy reasons
[Music]
we've read those
so I just want to make a couple of
points
firstly I think the build is further
pushing
um outside the towns to Define
settlement boundaries be it temporary
stamping into an area
Countryside character and really there
are no exceptions
I think the open the effect on the open
rural landscape will be considerable
um the proposed screening and that's
being suggested uh it was plants
completely unsuitable and agriculture
Essex anyway the screening that they
have proposed will have little time to
grow and present free to the visual Palm
a few months
I think the public building will
brutally harm the character and beauty
of this Countryside
the lucky invitation Garden Center
with really no accompanying perks
to Warrant planning permission I also
think this application will set a
precedent for the landlord to the site
to be developed I believe strongly that
think we land quite capable of ensuring
incremental changes to planning
permission so that a so-called temporary
build might become an application for
development of the site
and finally a most shocking for a
development that calls itself an
environmentally sustainable community
it provides no real concert
and in harmony
I'm sorry I'd have to stop you there
because the two minutes is two minutes
I'm sorry you'll have to stop thank you
thank you
thank you
[Music]
I'm sorry it sounds quite brutal but the
rules the rules apply to everybody and
if if somebody were from think Greenland
had been here this evening the same
would have applied okay so remember this
was this was callings committee by
Council Boyce who's not here this
evening it was called in uh under policy
H1 which is to do with affordable
housing but that's actually that that's
actually addressed in the body of the
report
um the recommendation uh by officers is
is to approve this application so is
that recommendation seconded by anybody
okay members I'll hand it over to you
then thank you
I think you know for the for the ease of
business you can stop when you get off
between questions as long as as long as
there's short questions and and that
applies equally to miss Dungey as well
to answer thank you
I just want to know
um
um don't get they get built after the
market value ones so he says that it's
going to be after a year but depending
on how quick they build action and that
could be this question is it going to be
longer than a year also my next question
is I thought this was a national
agricultural setting uh why are we
actually putting a modern Construction
in an agricultural setting I thought
there was rules about that
it seems to me as though we're actually
relaxing our roles for a developer so
it's got enough lands on the other side
to build a house a temporary house and
I've said myself today there's plenty of
room phase two has already been approved
if it doesn't want to put it or they
don't want to put it on phase one put it
on phase two what they're actually
trying to do in my opinion and it is
they're trying to do the sprawl we've
already gone outside
accommodate this Mass um
Village so what they're actually trying
to do is now set a precedent that if
you've got a development a dwelling and
they'll say that much probably and if Mr
Lee was here we'd say cancer stamp you
can only talk about what's in front of
you but you can guarantee they will come
back and say it's proved that it's
actually built in the countryside
there's no main issue about it it's not
doing any harm so I think there's a few
questions there so let's dungote there's
a couple of three questions there for
you yeah um thank chairman
um is my understanding that
and as per the committee report at
paragraph let me
3.1.11 that no more than 55 of the open
market dwellings may be occupied before
all of the affordable housing units have
been constructed
I was not the case officer for the
original application so I'm not sure if
the market housing or
what how long is that going to take to
build 55 well Kevin I I mean listen if
the Prime Minister doesn't understand
the economy I'm sure I don't but miss
dungote do you just want to or Mr
Johnson maybe yeah um I'm not quite sure
the reason for the question it's very
obviously
no the the application in front of us is
for a temporary uh building yeah
um I'm 12 months yeah or sooner
depending on the uh the building of the
permanent Showroom on the development
site that was incredible it's not tied
into the delivery of of affordable
housing or anything of that nature but
it's simply an application for a
temporary showroom to to to to to bring
forward the
um
sort of advertisement for the sales of
what will eventually be on the
development side it is not tied into the
development this is not related to
matters within the section 106. so with
all due respect counselor in my view
that question is not relevant to our
consideration of this application thank
you
yeah um through you chairman in relation
to the question about the agricultural
setting of the site
um as stated within the presentation the
site has actually been approved as the
uh construction compound for phase one
and
um this was initially due to
the fact that within if it was located
within phase one it would have to be
relocated if it was located within phase
two it would have to be relocated for
the build of the home so it was approved
on this site as it was separate to the
development site and given that it's
temporary in nature it can easily be
mitigated and removed from the site
um in terms of
the
the building itself so I think that was
there was a second part of
the
place
or does it
means it's a Johnston I think wants to
come back on that yeah thank you um
chair
um
as Mrs but miss dungote points out and
maybe it might be useful if you just
bring up that photograph which shows the
area which has been identified for the
construction compound
that site has been approved under a
discharge of condition
for basically where the works to
facilitate the development will take
place yeah so there will be construction
active related activity on that site for
the duration of of the development this
proposal would sit within that site
so the material facts in front of us is
that that area already has brought you
know the duration of the development has
been granted approval for its use as a
construction related site
so so that's the context in which this
building sits it's not in the while The
Wider site in general is within the open
Countryside for the duration of this
development that site has approval for
construction related site
um under the the the the the the
reference which has already been related
there would be vehicles coming and going
there'll be materials stored the
building that you can see on site in
that photograph is actually one of the
site offices there will be other
site-related buildings and a structure
within the confines of that development
so this temporary showroom this is not
this is not I mean it's laid out as a
house it will show the layout it will
show potentially this is what would be
one of the units this is not a dwelling
for further occupation it will not be
it's its extent will not be any greater
than what you can see uh on on that plan
there it's not for living in it will
have uh you know operatives or other
development who will be showing people
around here there will only be two
person at a time so basically
sorry can I I'm sorry you can't join the
conversation but I think that if you
read the report you'll probably find the
answer to your questioning in there
which will probably which should
probably satisfy you sorry
yeah so so really so that's the context
within which we see this this
development to to face within the open
Countryside and its impact if this were
not a construction site I could
appreciate those arguments and then we
can consider this merits but this is a
this is a case in which is within a
defined context of a site which has been
approved for con for for construction
related activity so did you want to come
back yeah
I don't believe it is a construction
site you've allowed a building to go on
there which is what this home Authority
allowed them to do where where is this
construction site office going to go
when you're now convert converted into a
shower pan
because is the need gone and I'll be
full because if you don't mind because
otherwise the chain is going to stop me
because I know if I go too far
um but every other developments that I
can speak of in Burnham and I'm sure
other other officers and other members
can say the same the one of the sick
knee on the molding Road they built a
temporary office on their site
everything was on their site they didn't
go anywhere else and it was then moved
and they put trees out in front which we
were annoyed at because we turned around
and said we don't want to see that
see everything but then they moved it so
why can't this
developer do the same why are they
building in our open Countryside I do
find it we've been very lenient to allow
them to build in our Countryside and
maybe they may may remove it but it
worked at this planning Authority one
that is planning teams
um problem it would be the enforcement
who is going to then have to go if they
don't take it down
and I I think that you know there is a
condition in here that says it has to be
removed after 12 months
um you know I mean we it's a very very
clear and enforceable
condition so
um I'll certainly come back to you but I
know that councilor Bessinger had his
hand up as well
I would just like to
agree with uh
I mean clearly I feel I think of the
issue again
always talks about setting to precedent
if you build a show home and it is the
layout or the home
somewhere down the line someone's going
to say well there is a house here so I
think we are setting real language we're
going to set a precipline I also don't
understand
because we had a construction Summit
which is therefore I consume the
materials for construction and then
you're saying we can then put a show
home on it and that's part of a
construction site I think that that
isn't the same thing
and I think it's absolutely correct
which councilor Spencer said you know
what happens to the office which now has
been converted into a show home where
will that go will that be another
that another building I mean this is
this is just open Countryside which is
going to be developed on with a show
home which will then set the president
for some to say we have a house on here
already
yeah okay so yeah
um Miss Johnson did you want to come
back thank you chair
um I I had the benefit of going to the
site um on my way down here
um which which is quite useful so
um the building is already there the
the use of that site as economists
what office building yeah
yeah it's not the children
the building is there and so I I use
that word for a specific purpose
um the the use of the site the activity
that would be related to the development
in itself has not even started yet yeah
um that will take place that that will
start at some point it's not it's the
the the sighting of of of a show home
and it's a show home it's not it's not a
dwelling no one's going to be living
there people will be taken their own
appointment they obviously if they
express interest and they will they will
have a look around and then they will go
obviously they discuss the usual things
that one discusses when one's looking to
purchase a home and then they will go
there will be no living there yeah it's
not it's not a living so it's so it's
not it's not a dwelling living amongst a
construction site as such and and and
and also it's not on even if we look at
the permanent home that in itself will
be within a development site here these
I've seen many of these over the years
in many development sites they are
normally screened off with of themselves
within the larger development sites
there's a safe obviously there's
regulations in which members of the
public will go onto construction sites
where you know there may be doing
something I would like to show through
so there's regulation in terms of that
so there's not a health and safety issue
here it's quite it's it's a normal part
of the development process for the show
home to be within the development side
this just happens to be within this
construction compound which is off the
site of the main development side thank
you chairman yeah of course
they have already landed why can they
not on the land they already have just
make a little area
like most developers do they don't go to
the next area so we want our show home
across the road because we developed
this bit you know that's that's their
development why am I not concerned thank
you chairman just to give the answer to
that the developers have come to us
because since the granting of planning
permission
um you have the section 106 and you also
have the section 278 related to Highway
works there has been a significant delay
with county in terms of signing the 278
agreement which will allow them to build
the road into the site to which they
will then be able to build the permanent
show home that isn't our problems well
this but this this but this is the basis
on which they've come forward to make
the application we've considered it an
honest marriage we've considered it in
terms of exciting were it were it the
case that it was just in open
Countryside
local plan Authority may have come to a
completely different position but it's
within the context of a site which
already has permission to be used as a
construction site it is a temporary
permission and that's the reason why we
are supporting it for this temporary
period thank you chairman okay thank you
um councilor Bell was next
no we're not I sort of well if you're
happy to give way I can only see the
hands as I do cancel the channel thank
you
German I should say
um
without respect don't we need to be
disrespectful to the officer I
appreciate the answers given however I
actually think I do
see what accounts will stand asks the
question she did
because actually there's a whole segment
within the report regarding affordable
housing stretching from Five Point power
5.3 right to
5.3.526 and that made the paragraph
5.3.5 it actually gives an indication
about possibly the timing of this
temporary building because it does make
association with the 106 agreement and
the fifth problem
of it okay and
the 55 of Market homes in association
with approved planning application and
it does make the point that it says it's
the intention that the show home and
marketing Suite will permit The Prompt
sale of the remaining Market homes and
this will lead to the quick occupation
of the site so I think councilor stance
point was sort of seeking to try and get
was there an indication of what that
timing might be I think that work
Council stands coming from dissociation
with affordable housing and the timing I
don't know all the aspects that
councilor passengers made but and I
appreciate you say there's no help in
the safety issue
well I've been through it past there a
few times and actually it looks to me
that it is part of a construction site
there is that building there you've got
the carbuncle Farm Etc and I'm sure I've
seen a fair number of vehicles on there
now this is going to be people coming
and going onto a show home are we
totally confident that there is actually
no going to be no competition with any
site vehicles whatsoever
Johnson I don't know if you're going to
answer that
through your chair um there is there is
a a fair amount of that which I cannot
answer I'm sort of working backwards
from the health and safety side health
and safety in itself is not a planning
related matter obviously something we
take into consideration but it's not a
plan and related related matter the
there are conditions applied uh on this
site in the usual way in which we
consider client applications in terms of
height relates to any other buildings
moving you know to and fro that's not
really part of our planning
considerations
um
now just going back to the affordable
housing and
I do appreciate more the context of the
question now so I I I do accept that
this is uh the general comment which
relates to how the the showroom the
permanent showroom relates to the
section 106 in terms of delivery of
affordable housing of itself it is not
directly relevant to this particular
application only in the sense that the
applicant is trying to ensure that they
can start the marketing as soon as they
would have liked to had they had the two
section seven eight in in place and on
the site and the showroom developed in
the location it would have that is not
the case unfortunately because of the
issues with a county and the under
Section 278 as as I've said before
um that really is the context within
which we just have to see this
affordable housing affordable housing in
this aspect is not something which if
members felt that way other than just
elucidation
um related to the consideration of this
development in front of us thank you
chairman thank you
I'm sorry can I can I go back to
accounts for the chance because
councilor Channel explanation no I use
the word solution but but that's what it
means
regarding any site traffic or indeed any
um
the application
I think what I'm hearing I'm very
concerned about and I think we ought to
take this up with the County Council is
it appears to be that some issues are
surrounding the County Council other two
seven eight agreement I think
so I find that quite concerning but I'm
sure that's the matter we could continue
outside of this meeting together okay
thank you councilor Bell thank you
I'm very concerned about people coming
to look at a showroom a great big Lobby
is coming back into the forwards and
added that into the mix the fact that
Tinkers hold is a rat rod I know I use
it yeah you get stuck down into Dory
when you're coming around the burner bin
so you've had a right and tear down this
straight into Mr and Mrs Bolton coming
to look at the show home but I
appreciate that highways are set to a
real issue so but I'm still not fully
understanding why this whole show home
can all be built if not
is too soy which is only where do you've
been agreed for development so there's
already this vacant piece of land that
has already been earmarked
while we can't it go there why does it
have to go
to go here which just does seem like a
ball because of more expression Place
well you know
right okay did you want to come back on
any of those points I don't think we can
really understand the mind of the the
applicant and uh you know you know it's
worth noting that there's nobody here
tonight representing the applicants so
that's the same do you know they may
well have developed that misdunge did
you want to say anything yeah of course
I'm just going to say through
and there is obviously two conditions
um within the app the recommendation to
state that it shall be removed within
the by the 12 month end date
um and shall be used as a show home only
you could suggest a condition or amend
that condition to say once the
um
the actual show home within the site is
built this show home shall be removed
the temporary show home but that that's
the developers have
confirmed that they would remove this
show home once the actual show home is
built whichever is sooner is that well
hang on a moment Miss Dungeon Because I
thought you said that this this building
had to be removed after 12 months and
now you're saying it's when the show
homes delivered but we know that Essex
highways haven't signed off the entrance
to the site which is I guess is what the
problem which has caused all this
um so could you just clarify that today
it was confirmed that the section 2 278
agreement has been signed
and the agent stated we could say that
to alleviate any of your concerns so
that should bring forward the
development of the show home within the
site so if the temporary commission was
allowed for this show home a condition
could be stated to say it shall be
removed by the 12-month period or
once this the actual show home within
the phase one site has been I'm not sure
that I don't think that's quite where
members are going I I think they would
prefer yeah I I I you know I think that
the condition that it needs to be
removed within 12 months is the backstop
we don't need to caveat that because if
they can't sort out their Road onto the
site you know they've had their 12
months it's a marketing suite and it's
there for a purpose but and and just to
clarify for everyone that's here S6
highways have no objections to this
um and they'll be fully aware of uh
tinker's hole and the importance to
Drive slowly along there as well
councilor bill
um yeah so yeah I was just thinking if
it might be useful to appear some of the
texts of what the what the applicant
says yeah yeah yeah yeah
um thank you chairman
um I mean I I had a conversation with
the applicant just this afternoon around
this around this very matter reason
some of the issues
and and I received two emails explaining
their position I just thought it might
be useful as they interpreter not here
just to hear what they have to say
um
yeah so can we just can we just hear
what this is just sort of tied into what
we're saying here right so it's as as as
Hannah just said
um the the 278 agreement has now just
been signed yeah
um
um and
um and space has been booked for the
formation of the site entrance in
November
2022 the permanent show home is in the
first trance of Bungalows and will be
commenced as soon as the highway
entrance is open probably in late
December but I'll say say early January
this may provide hopefully some comfort
to members that the developers
progressing the permanent show home with
all speed yeah and clear for them it's
it's in their interest to have the show
home on the development site itself
rather than off-site because I do
appreciate it I went there myself I know
exactly what that Rose like it's not
ideally the best place you'd actually
want to take people to view what's going
to be your you know premium development
but it's just as it is so so so that is
the case so in my view and and
it's it's they could the the show home
will be developed within the 12 months
they have to either way the show the the
the temperature will have to go so for
us that's
additional Comfort although as far as
we're concerned in terms of the
permission that the recommendation we
put to members there is enough
safeguards in that that development will
be removed by 12 months if not before
thank you chairman so I mean you know Mr
Johnson sort of slightly uncomfortable
because ordinarily if the developer had
anything to say or the applicant had
anything to say they would do it
formally and it should come as a
member's update
um you know I understand what you're
trying to do but it members aren't wait
that according to how the information
has arrived with the planning Authority
so uh Miss dunga did you want to add
anything at this stage no
um like could I ask some questions that
that may help please chairman right and
look forward to hearing those
and because a few months ago my you know
my inbox is always full my understanding
was that the developer here was using
the Stony Hillside for show homes
because
I knew you've got the same amount of
emails as I did about construction about
the traffic going and people showing
them around the homes in Stony Hills I
know you're going to say it's not
relevant but to me the next point is
I it's my understanding of how many
homes have they sold Off plan already
because I I think it all comes into the
picture because I'm I'm a negative
meaning I don't believe what people tell
me without facts and evidence and I from
the way that this application is
developing phase two phase three is now
coming up I would imagine that they've
sold them phase one I would have thought
would have been blown out the Wind by
now at all been sold so my argument is
and you'll say to me it's not a planning
argument and I get used to talking and
trying to talk me down is if they come
to build it in December why why do they
have to start building it now for two
months it's eight weeks why why take the
risk of having a development in our
local Countryside in another
agricultural area where I know those
built those Farm track those Farm things
are going to break big spray things go
in and out there because I followed him
the other day so it's a
Health chairman and
I feel very passionate about this if we
start building outside of another
development boundary we are opening
ourselves up okay so yeah I mean
I mean you know the highways I'm afraid
that you know if the highways
authorities say that they're satisfied
with the what's going to happen on that
there's nothing you know that this plan
and Authority can do we have to we're
we're just have to accept that and and I
think everything else and all the other
information you've given that that
you've been privy to again you know
members is up to you how you want to
weight that
um cancel the bill you've got your hand
up
my head in this
sausages has just done the opposite of
justifying it yes I'm telling us and
don't correctly Please Mr Johnson if
I've got this wrong by accident tell me
this the African can't be bothered to
wait two months
well I think because yeah
I think I think what Miss Johnson you
know it's very difficult to understand
yeah
but if they if they if they've got the
agreement now with their Essex County
Council to open the road so they can
start that in a couple of months time I
think they said so they've got to
construct that they then got to build
this first trunch of Bungalows which is
going to include the show home and you
know that's probably going to take it
may well take 12 months to do that I
don't know but the the key to this is is
that you know the office has been very
helpful in conditioning in this and to
say that this building must go after 12
months so I'd like to think that would
encourage them to get on with building
the showroom
um
councilor Channel
but thank you chairman if I made I'm
just looking
um at the conditions and you look at
conditions and actually it's coming to
me when I was sitting here and if you
read these things and it doesn't always
sink in just a couple of prayers on that
um it does say
um the condition number four planning
permission does not extend to the two
meter high Timber screen fence with
applied mineral graphics
incorrect but and then it says prior to
occupation details and drawings of the
proposed to being a long line of design
are to be submitted to so one condition
saying in no way does the planning
extend to defense
and then we're saying prior to
occupation details and drawings of the
proposed renal vinyl design are to be
submitted to an approved in writing by
the local planning Authority so on the
one hand we're saying it doesn't include
it unless I'm sorry I do apologize I'm
equally well with the misinterpreting
the intentions here but to me I see it a
contradiction between those two
conditions should we stop and just ask
the officer and then we'll go yeah oh
sorry yeah I'll come back here
I'm just digesting what what's been said
yeah there's a fence that's been
proposed within the no I couldn't see it
I mean we might I mean if
but we can you know depending where
where would you go with this members we
can deal with both of those conditions
four and five did you want to come come
back okay
um
it says the occupation of the site shall
be limited to a show home and marketing
Suite associate blah blah blah blah and
again the Word occupation is used later
on in another condition why don't we say
the use of the site I mean occupation to
me immediately made me think something's
going to be occupied yeah regarding
those buildings where as I would have
thought it would say the use of the site
should be limited and then at the end of
it and shall not at any time be occupied
for any other use shouldn't it say and
shall not be if any time be any other
use the word of occupied in that
condition and further down so it is
about the occupation I think it ties up
because I just referred to that um it is
condition number five prior to
occupation details anyways the Word
occupation to me means that something is
more permanent something's going to be
occupied yeah rather than a use so I
just like some Transportation I think I
think the offices are a slight
disadvantage because I don't think you
vote the report did you but I mean you
know occupy can apply to occupying a
suite of
occupying could be you know
sorry occupying could be a suite of
offices or it could be a property I mean
it's used but I mean again if members
were minded you could change that
commission at that point that uh
condition to say use
um members does anybody want to come
back with anything else
so we have a uh offices there's anything
else you want to add no the only thing
would be I I can agree with you Council
China I have no no problem with the use
of the word I wouldn't take occupation
probably to the extent you have but I'm
I'm quite happy if members were mining
to approve uh the the use of the word
use
okay so we'll go back to the
recommendation
um the recommendation by officers is to
approve the application I called for
that to be seconded and uh no one
indicated that they would so members the
planning Authority is led by you now
um I propose that we do reduce the
opposite against an officer's
recommendation and I'm sure you've
forgiven the policy numbers
um if I just tell you what it is you can
tell me which policies can you put your
that can do yes yes I don't have a
problem with that but can you tell the
officers on what grounds you wish to
refuse it thank you
well I think that the planting I know we
didn't debate in that chairman because
I've said too much how American 12
months they can actually screen
something off um that it isn't causing
harm material harm is beyond me unless
they're going to get some huge trees
and I do think you can see it I think
I've read somewhere in the report that
it isn't visible if you go to old old
Heath and you're coming down to this
hole it sticks down like a sore thumb if
it is now so so I don't believe it is
not intrusive into the countryside
they're the ones that I think off the
top of my head Mr chairman
um okay so
um
in an agricultural area and it is Brick
and wood so it doesn't fit is the world
in Congress yeah
I'm supposed to be here
[Music]
well hang on man does any other member
want to add to that list
which I don't think would apply this is
not going to be lived in
but without that I just I I cannot see I
I cannot see it justify the minute
that's whether that's a funny result I
don't think it sort of that's you know
the lead doesn't matter really that's
what the application is all to do
um Miss bird I hope I hope you're there
can you um just give the the committee a
crazy of the the reasons for refusal
please
um some of the reasons that were
mentioned by councilor stump was the
being outside the development boundary
intrusive in the countryside and
planting uh visible that it can be seen
and the design being an agricultural
area doesn't fit in with the countryside
that's what I've got a noted down
apologies if I've missed anything
just help me
because
like okay I've
done yes
but I think your proposal is is that the
application is refused
um in relation to policies S1 S8 D1 and
H4
on the points that you've raised within
those policies and I think that that
would that helps Miss dungate and I
think the Clark actually has your
narrative to support your proposal for
refusal based on those policies
um so members if you are happy with that
is that proposal seconded
councilor Bell thank you those in favor
of refusing this paying the application
in relation to policies S1 S8 D1 and H4
please show
the application is refused thank you
foreign
members of the public I don't know if he
wants to stay but if you want to leave
this is a good time before we start
getting on to the the other and thank
thank you very much for coming thank you
sorry Hannah that was um
um
very good
place
I fell asleep
thank you
my members let's continue please
gender item six
the dingy hundred Sports Center Station
Road Burnham on Crouch it's uh before us
uh as it's a council owned building and
also a member call in by councilor Bell
and there is a recommendation to refuse
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a single story extension
to the existing clubhouse at the sports
center the application follows a
previously refused application for a
similar development under the terms of
21 forward slash zero zero nine one one
forward slash ful whilst no changes have
been made to the layout of the proposed
extension the design has been amended so
that the roof of the building would have
a hit reform instead of flat rooform
this is the site location plan for the
application the site is located on the
Northern side of millfields and is
partially within the settlement boundary
of Burnham Crouch to the west of the
site are the playing fields associated
with the sports club and to the north
and east is residential development
this is the existing block plan for the
application as you can see there are 16
existing car parking spaces which serve
the existing Sports Center
and this is the proposed block plan
um as you can see there would be a loss
of six car parking spaces
um and the location of the extension
would also render the six car parking
spaces opposites unusable due to the
limited space between them for
maneuvering of vehicles
these are the existing elevations of the
flat roof structure at the Sports Center
and these are the
proposed elevations of the previously
refused application which was refused on
poor design and inadequate parking at
the site
these are the proposed elevations of the
extension as part of the current
application which show a revised reform
for the proposed extent extension which
would not relate to the existing
building and would exacerbate the poor
design of the existing building which
would cause visual harm to the character
of the area
this is the existing floor plan of the
clubhouse
and this is the proposed floor plan
showing the extension which would
accommodate additional changing rooms as
well as well as other Associated
facilities including referee Rooms store
room
Etc
this is an aerial photograph submitted
with the application showing the
location of public park car parks
located within nearby vicinity of the
site
and this is a photograph of the existing
Clubhouse which is considered to be of
poor design and limited architectural
Merit
this is the location of the proposed
extension which would be highly visible
within the street scene and from public
Vantage points
these are photographs of the existing
car park
and these are photographs of just one of
the car Parks which is located at the
junction of millfields with Station Road
as well as on-street car parking that is
occurring along millfields at the moment
it is understood that restrictions have
been removed from the road
so which is allowing car parking along
the street
um so although the revised design has
sought to overcome the harm previously
identified within the previous refusal
the revised design would in some ways be
worse than the original proposal as it
would not relate to the existing
building in any way
due to its height width and depth it
would not be considered to be
subservient in scale or form to the
existing building and the blank blank
wall of the extension which faces
millfields would be visually
unattractive and would exacerbate the
poor design of the existing structure
and the new structure
the proposed development would also
result in an inadequate level of on-site
car parking provision for a building of
this size which is likely to result in
even more additional on-street car
parking
um to the detriment of the amenity and
convenience of residents
the application is therefore recommended
for refusal on this basis
thank you Tim thank you we have one
speaker on this application it's the
supporter Mr London
London a few uh
take a seat you will have two minutes to
escape your case from the time you start
speaking and at two minutes be the end
of it good evening my name's Robert
London I am the current president of the
Rugby Club and first I'd like the
federal planning committee for the
opportunity to speak on the plans we
have considered the objections of the
planning officer and would like the
committee to consider the following we
adjusted the plans following the
original objection to include a pitched
roof even though the new building is
linked to the existing building which
consists of a flat roof a pitch roof and
a diamond roof the requirement to add
Wing knows the design is not in
compliance with standards set by
sporting bodies such as the rfu and
addition give rice to safeguarding
issues for the use of children wishing
to change shower after playing
the width of the building taken into
account with the minimum dimensions for
changing rooms to accommodate teams for
up to 22 players this again complied
with appropriate standards set by
sporting bodies it is also noted that
sport England and the rfu are supposedly
fully supportive of this the planned
Extinction represents a significant
upgrade to the current facility which
does not meet appropriate standards and
could result in clubs not having change
in the solicit for children the club is
not asking for any financial support for
the development which will be borne by
the clutch with regards to the parking
although the council suggest the loss of
six spaces we have agreed with NDC that
an extension of four further spaces
could be made available by extending the
current parking from the disabled spaces
on the road by the public toilets into
into the addition of the existing car
parking available on the access road of
the car parts at the top bottom of the
road amount into approximately 80 spaces
we have also since agreed with burn
Training Club and Burnham Yacht Harbor
an additional 80 spaces if and when
required we do not anticipate an
increase in traffic from what we're
currently seen on the two three days the
club runs activities
finally with regards to the proposity
government this is being established for
the use of cricket Crow code pubs and
we're looking to see how this could be
extended for more Community Access
especially Local Schools clubs such as
burden Park
thank you very much thank you
um
with an opportunity
interest I'm a member of a croquet Club
so um
I
think it's the decision has to be yours
I don't know how that would be viewed
um
nails for this so I'm sure Sovereign
[Music]
yeah I mean obviously anything you do
you've got to satisfy yourself that
you're that you're happy to do it and
you can tend to visit I
and I have discussed this with the
monitoring officer and he did advise
that on if I call in an application that
actually even without an interest it
might be wise to speak to Advocate
rather than vote so I'm confident from a
lawful perspective that if I do that but
I I would be okay I don't know what new
challenges so if I may do that you may
do that the decisions
I don't I mean I don't think it's a
pecuniary interest as such but I'm not
even sure whether it I don't know I
don't know enough to be safe because
the only the only thing he jeopardize is
yourself so it's
but I mean as far as like as far as I
can see and I'm certainly not an expert
I think you're all right to speak going
beyond that I don't know if the if the
monitoring officer advised that then I
don't see that there's a problem doing
that
okay but um I'll come back to you in
just a moment Council Mr Slim yeah
and I wasn't allowed to to vote for
their kids I could listen no this week
but I didn't vote which I found really
annoying because it says he pays that
it's got nothing to do with me
that wields the Mallet on Wednesday
afternoon so I will look on my yes
actually hearing the full story here
which is that this application is not in
any small part helping out NDC place
that people have struggled with the
running of the sports center it's not
made money I think it loses money so the
Rugby Club came along with a proposal
to rescue the situation and to actually
take on some of the running costs I
believe in order to alleviate depression
old account so and improve and enhance
the facilities for Burnham
so it just seems to me really beside so
I don't know if I know the saying you
know the right hand doesn't know what
the left hand is doing it appears that
the right hand is trying to bite the
left hand off in this case because this
proposal benefits Burnham and NDC
and I know I'm uh
if I forget what a word is but
um
yeah
you can't turn us a salesy you can't
make a perfect salary and can you and I
don't honestly think there's a lot you
could do that would make this area of
fun but any worse
and that really sort of Suits anything
else is really morphed by that
the housing around is the sort of 1960s
block bill
housing some parking spaces indeed the
currently used by residents of that
which is what which they shouldn't be
using
and I just think really the benefits of
this application out wearing any harms
to such a degree but I really can't
understand why we're even intubating it
so that's all I've got to say thank you
very much Council bill
customer system yes thank you I think
it's a great shame the Rugby Club came
many years ago to do a proposal to do a
presentation and they wanted to do
fantastic things for this building but
they've got nowhere yeah I think we've
lost out on many years of
um you know they wanted to put glass
balustrade on there and balcony and so
it's a really nice restaurant to Eatery
and it's totally turned away why why do
we never ever invest in local businesses
Sports places that want to add value to
our beautiful town in Vernal clutch in
our district I can't believe it's been
refused A recommended refusal twice
there have spoken to the officers to try
and make it better I actually said to
cancel the Bell put some cladding on it
that's what I've done to my ass it's not
the value or purport dude because it
looks so much better it the beauty is in
the eye of the beholder that they're not
doing any harm to that building it is
not a very pleasant building and while
they are occupying it it is not going
into drinks and drugs and going on to
the park where it's going used we all
love having the officers running around
the park chairman when they're playing
there they've been doing their training
it lights up the whole of the town and I
cannot believe that the officers yet
again have offered said it's a
recommended refusal on those grounds it
enhances the district in the area and I
certainly will not be supporting the
office of recommendation to refuse
Jeremy Council Mr Chandler was next and
Council fluka thank you very much
the layout so the floor plan and the
block plan would be the same but it's
just the elevations that have changed
there was a flat roof before wasn't
there which went down parking can do
yes this is the this is the through you
chairman this is the proposed elevations
of the previous application
so that was a flat room which wasn't um
seen acceptable in the parking yeah can
you show the the new proposal I think is
it because the increase of 1.7 liters
you feel is the main part
um you know you feel that um is worse I
think the report actually feels that
it's worse than what we've previously
yeah um for you chairman that's that's
part of the reason that the designer
seem to be unacceptable that's not the
whole reason it's a combination of the
extensive flank wall that is blank which
is facing the Street Scene It is the
combination of the height of the
extension which is actually higher than
the existing building
um the depth of it at the width of it
sorry obviously I understand I don't
know the history of the site in terms of
what was proposed previously if that's
ever I mean as a planning application
but
officers support the enhancement of the
community facilities obviously in the
right way so if there was the
opportunity for example that the
existing flat roof building was
demolished and a two-story extension was
proposed you know that's something
obviously that's not before us today and
that's not viable possibly for the Rugby
Club but we have to consider the
lifetime of the development not just the
use of it for the Rugby Club and
presumably it's only going to get more
popular so the the harm and the visual
harm of this extension
and the loss of the car parking is
obviously what we consider to outweigh
the benefits of the skin in this
instance
if I may just uh one thing that concerns
me with this is
you cannot unless you agree to a flat
roof extension that any extension is
always going to be higher than the
existing building
you can't you can't you can't get away
from that well the
X the extension could be a first floor
extension a two-story extension it could
be to the rear of the building the this
is not the only option that could happen
obviously that is what is before us
today and that is what we have to
consider we're not we aren't considering
any other options but if you know we
could discuss that with the applicant as
part of the preact process
at the moment
we have to consider this yeah
we consider that it's customer Channel
you want to come back on that thank you
um
I do have sympathies with what the
officer has presented actually in terms
of
the design but also it's that car
parking at that original refusal it was
previously and was again appearing and
that's what I'm going around in my
consideration is just a connection well
this is the rest of the debate okay
cancer fluid I think at this point it's
worth noting that we actually will have
a discount
and yes it is
I mean I appreciate the planning
department um
engage with other departments in the
council but I believe from a commercial
point of view there has been several
conversations with Burnham Rugby
Football Club house to address this
problem that they
have and that's actually include looking
at all of the options that we've
I think we're in a very much of a
chicken and egg situation here I mean
commercial and I know it's not a kind of
reason but I will just say that I do
know that
the service delivery side of the council
are vacuum to see this succeed because
it helps them enormously in their
commercial activities with dealing with
places and I think it's fair to say that
probably
now just a couple of points generally
we're talking is is worth speaking to
and one is the council's adoptive
vehicle uh parking standards the VPS
document
um it it is guidelines and it is
guidance although it is an extra
development and I accept that but when
it when it speaks to sports and
recreational uses it mentions the one
parking space for 22 meters
um and then it goes on to say our
individual assessment and justification
well really a truly basically you know
it seems to me that I mean the people
behind me can justify it someone's
assessed it and it seems to be a case
that needs must
there is a lot of parking nearby I know
the the parking that's been mentioned by
the applicants is officed I said we
can't really consider it but in our
minds we know it's there and it can be
used there is an argument about whether
or not
but then again there's a huge amount of
car parking space is taken up by the
recycling bins and all of the type of
places that surround them if the council
did their clear database they certainly
invest another four or five car parking
space so I I think that the the VPS is
flexible enough to allow for this
so that then takes me on to design now
you know the greatest respect to a
previous Southeast area planning
committee
um the the daily 100
um Sports Center is never going to get
an architecture
and we've all talked about car bundings
before but you know it is pretty ghastly
and you know one one thinks that in my
mind I think if we've got a ghastly
building and the planning officers the
Same by using different Expressions this
looks ghastly to me if you had all the
gas in this together then it all fits in
I mean
we've had a we've had a sort of a based
group you know we've had a pitched roof
and then you know and then they were
told that's no not suitable then we've
gone back to the flat roof and it's not
much in between the Chairman's um quiet
right and then we've got this other
thing which is you know slight mowing in
this Farm the fact that we've got a
blank wall and the reason why I've got
to take all this and I'll check this is
that you know these Sports and
institutions that have changed rooms
they're not supposed to have Windows
directly going into the change rooms
because the safeguarding issues now I
know that's not a planning issue but I
think that when you look at the policy
dick one you think to yourself well
actually is this acceptable so we've got
that and then we've got the highest set
the highest the height because that's
what's required for building regulations
and the width is really a matter of of
needs
must
so
I sort of based on that channel I I
think in my view
is that taking everything into the
simulation with regards to design
and
thinking about what officers are saying
about the roof and thinking about what
they're saying about the the windows and
I think it's worth mentioning at this
time they appears to be a shed on top of
one of them I mean there was a members
update came out today with a picture and
it appears to have a shed on the top I
mean this obviously adds to the
architecture and Technology
reactor in there as well we've got this
shed you know and I'm sort of thinking
you know the shed the strap roof and
then we're going to put another flat
roof over
but in this particular instance it's
interesting because we tried to address
it with a pitch roof that the pain
Authority said no they've come back with
that one they say no
um I I believe that there's sufficient
um the way
and it should be treated separately we
know that there's alternative department
but really true shouldn't we bang
shouldn't we
build all over the car parking spaces or
turn them into a rugby bridge and make
everybody walk because this is what
we're supposed to be doing building
places
but I think based on that chairman I
would say that it is exceptional in that
way and because of that we can apply
those two words for big respect stand as
a document and and I think that the
design does fit in
so for those
reasons China I propose that we agreed
that's seconded second did
um yes so um in terms of the Point Break
You Raised about parking that obviously
has been considered as part of the
application
um and we did make an assessment based
on the fact that the building is being
extended by 213 square meters which
equates to 10 additional car parking
spaces being required obviously the
extension is resulting in the loss of
six car parking spaces as well as the
six car parking spaces opposite so
that's 12 car parking spaces plus the 20
um at the 10 additional car parking
spaces that aren't going to be gained by
the proposed development so that's a
loss of 22 car parking spaces obviously
inter oh my maths might be off sorry
either way I think the report says
six all together this is deficit
assistance
foreign
places Leisure they'll provide those
extra parking spaces and we can't we
can't condition that but I really do
think that on this occasionally we
should and can I just clarify about the
design sorry because you mentioned that
it's a flat roof design this application
is not for the flat roof it's for the
history
I do I do remember a few years ago for a
restaurant in
Station Road Malden District Council are
happy to accept the fact there was a big
car park opposite five ways Council Mr
channel do you remember that
I can't remember where the which which
restaurant it was now it was somewhere
in Station Road
and um so you know there is a lot of car
parking public car parking in and around
the area so yeah hi Mr Johnson
that's about my my my only point there
is um again just how we apply policy
um it's not just this application it's
it's how we're consistent with applying
policies
across the various applications that we
have in front of us a number of the
points that members are making are not
within the justification of the
application
um
there are not particular matter for
officers to be considering at the time
when the report was prepared so we are
considering all the facts that were in
front of us we are considering in terms
of how we apply our policies how our
policies may be interpreted generally
um and I think as we do normally say
we're very mindful of decisions that may
go against how we may normally uh in in
the majority of cases apply our policy
unless there is the justification
justification is being presented by the
members with members gift but I am just
given the precautionary caveat as is
necessary in terms of these decisions we
go against our policies thank you very
much Jessica
[Music]
is
German a lot of people run down
but you see them
now take something else once they have a
really good way they're trying to raise
funds nobody drives because otherwise
you have to go and pick them up the
lockers
so you know there's not a lot of cars
outside
anybody else wish to speak anything new
um
and I can't see how you could
describe the design of that but if
something was similar but to be honest
unless we've got another shape
parking spaces
parking stages there are easily
thank you
guys
I don't think I don't think I don't
think we ought to be quiet
like Memphis and there's anybody else
there's a proposal in the name of
Council of Luca seconded by cancer Mr
stem
two
foreign
to
officer recommendation
those in favor of that please show one
two three four those are games one in
that case it is approved
[Music]
I think you came out today
[Music]
is
[Music]
and conditions
standard conditions
[Music]
in consultation with the chairman of
course yeah
[Music]
okay
everybody happy with that
move on gender item seven to
number five vicarage
it's not Chinese
[Music]
too
right are you all ready
agenda item seven five vicarage Lane
demolition of existing conservatory and
construction of a one and a half story
extension with new Dormers with Windows
storm porch additional roof windows and
Patio and raised patio area to the
career it's before us due to remember
calling by councilor Fluker and there is
an officer recommendation also to refuse
thank you chairman
the application's explanation for the
demolition of the existing Conservatory
in construction of a one and a half
story extension with new Dormers Roof
Windows stormport additional reprint
days and Patio and race patio area to
the rear the application site is located
on the southern side of vicarage Lane
outside the settlement boundary of
tillingham but within this hillingham
Conservation Area
the site is occupied by detached
Bungalow does area is rural with small
groups of dwellings located in between
agricultural fields
to the north of the site there is a
recreation there are Recreation grounds
immediately adjacent to the east of the
application sizes number three victridge
lane which is a grade two listed
building it's also located within the
wider setting of Clifton which is a
locally used building
this is the third submission of the
application with the last application
that was refused uh
22.00474 and slash house and no
Amendments have been made since that
application was refused
this is the location plan
50 proposed block plan
these are the proposed fronts
side with elevation
ground floor plan
the most personal plan
this is the existing block plan
[Music]
ES
this is the existing floor plan
and this is the existing and the
proposed routines
so the site photographs so this is the
view outside Clifton placed in West
blue building is the application site
this is from outside of the cottage next
door facing west
this is from outside vicarage Lane
facing south
this is a view from the entrance of the
bowls club based in southwest
zoomed in a closer photo
this is from directly outside the
boundary of number five
the southwestern laundry
from within the within the recreational
ground opposite the application site
and this is another view
from the corner Facing East along the
Bridge Lane
so in conclusion is considered that the
proposed extension by reason of its
overall design scale relationship with
the host dwelling and position would
result in a dominant disproportionate
and unsympathetic addition to the
existing dwelling to the detriment of
the character of the appearance thereof
and the surrounding area which is a
conservation area so development is
therefore not in accordance with the
stipulations policies D1 D3 and H4 of
the approved local development plan and
guidance contained within the national
policy framework it's
nothing shows
within the conversation area but it's
we have one
two speakers sorry the first one is Mr
Alex Robinson who is the applicant's
agent
Mr Robinson
you've got two minutes from the time to
start speaking to make your case
so yes good evening councilors I hope
everyone as well thank you for allowing
me to speak in such a late station today
regarding a project to find recruiter
Lane as mentioned
consistoric buildings despite this the
existing property is without a child
it's not architecturally of Interest it
has no positive impact on the street
scene there's no positive impact on
Heritage assets next door there's no
positive impacts for the conservation
area or otherwise the design aims of The
Proposal stamped primarily
otherwise might
as well that beauty and that's what
absolute appropriateness to the
surrounding area
and for those who enjoy it
council's own highly experienced and
specialist conservation officer is
wholly supportive of the scheme no doubt
because he understands significant
benefit and undoubtable Improvement in
rooms
it bewilders me as to why the
non-conservation specialist the case
officer then ignores their colleagues
advice entirely and adds conservation as
a reason for refusal respectfully this
and decisions related to conservation
should be
leadership
office ultimately the addition of just
half a story being the point of
contention is an entirely normal and
wide
a very local matching examples gives
telling them the quality charm it
obviously has the vast vast majority of
properties being a two-story setting the
vernacular but the almost non-existent
this proposal would only add to the
richness for the area as mentioned in
the existing building sadly has no
positive impact to the area
we would we could have a refusalem what
remains as a poorly attached an
unrelated
building it could be said to be jarring
against
alternatively with the approval
I will get a far improved high quality
traditional building with beautiful
detail and Heritage materials
um and the chairman of telling a Village
Council yes no
no
a member of
you you wish to speak now do you like
yes if you come around here
um
take take seat with the microphone
as before you have two minutes from the
time you start speaking when you're
ready
very much a last-minute addition to
I am how Grimes
in tillingham we have discussed this
within returningham Council and it was a
unanimous decision that we backed this
um everybody that obviously is in the
council knows the area and sees how
at the moment this property doesn't fit
in
through no
folks and she's very much prepared to
bring this within my of the rest of the
village I know for fact because I spoke
to them today the neighbors and
decide that is the grade two listed
building have no complaints about
proposals
um has already been said it's been
absolutely identified by the Tim
Harrison Specialist of conservation and
Heritage that he says I advise The
Proposal called no harm to the
significance of the Heritage assets
why
one of the other things that I just
didn't quite understand is that I
understanding the planning officer's
statement it was
towards Slaughter Junction there's a
bends there there is a small pathway
that goes into the Bowls Club
so
irregularly and
felt that perhaps the area wasn't quite
understood
okay thank you very much
[Music]
yeah I mean
[Music]
yourself
the office
this is
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
foreign
totally
70s
so I think this is great opportunities
of course you've got this aspects
either
way
really
really be hard to argue
we can't argue with another
so I think that is
foreign
officer has got no objection to it I've
found it a bit peculiar that we're
trying to the office of recommendation
is to refuse it on Conservation Area
grounds Mr Johnson
thank you chair
um
just a couple of things and um firstly I
I just want to say it's it's not just
um an officer going completely against
the conservation
area officers comments I mean the
comments are far more extensive than
what's just represented in the uh
in the in the officers report and
there's a whole number of practice when
we could have
a development
the conservation and listed building
officers is very much based around that
remit the design issues does
fall very much within with planning
officers as well so just need to make
that that distinction as to why there
may be some Shock and horror if we go
against what the conservation area
Officer says yeah
um in terms of the existing building
um
if we
um look at 5.2.6
um it talks about the building that
exists it talks about it being better as
part of a small cluster of dwellings
including the grade two lifted building
Etc
all three Cottages or there are varying
scales and appearance
considered as having value as a group
and they're all of a relatively small
scale so when we're considering the
conservation here is it's not just the
individual look of the building whether
it looks old whether it looks of a
particular design
part of the conservation area and how we
would
Define an air as a conservation area is
also very much based on this group value
and the group value in these three
buildings is based on how they are so
that is a consideration of offices in
terms of preserving a conservation area
that was one of the original principles
in terms of defining the various
elements of the conservation area
um
so um that's very much a valid reason in
terms of us not supporting this
application from a Conservation Area
point of view and you know there are
there are significant issues which are
raised in the subsequent
um
again that's within members give but the
reasons why officers are not supporting
this application are very much valid
very much the reason within which
any other scheme where there is a
excessive domination of an extension
over an existing building would not
normally be supported it would not
normally record and it's actually
contrary to the working of the policy if
we read it so
um
this is not just a really nearly view
given by officers who it may be
considered do not have remake if they
move to comment on design this is very
much the case very much applying the
policy and this is very much consistent
with the policy as I said the
Conservation Area consideration and
whether the conservation area supports
it or not is one of the considerations
within the gift of officers to consider
thank you chairman thank you very much
to Johnson we don't think
and we actually do value
recommendations and the reports we just
sometimes have a different view so
please please
just I just need to come back on that it
wasn't political in terms of members but
in terms of in terms of the totality of
the of the of the input into this
meeting it was not just members
utility
Council Mr Channel
s
says
and then further home
so the amendments are relation in
relation to the second application that
we received so
certification we received was refused a
second application was received and
there were some minor design
um alterations that included foot
Rafters and some of the materials
um from memory but this application
there was no amendments from that second
application but it was amended from the
very first application if you look at
all three if you compared all three two
and three oh this one compared to number
one so there were some minor and then
that was in line with some comments with
Tim's comments on the first application
um
be this time
that even if you take
them and I think that you know
how important it is
but you know
which you can't really do much
you
think that would be
in any way
besides
in a previous refusal I think the
officers
so yeah
[Music]
um
we have a proposal in the name of cancer
flu because seconded by councilman
Casper
um to approve the
application contact office of
recommendations
um I think you come up with satisfactory
reasons for that
because
leader
there were some suggested comments and
conditions and that Tim added to the end
of his
um full consultation response in
relation to the windows and the
weatherboarding and the
top interview
started
but there's in favor of approval please
show one two three four five it's uh
unanimous
okay in that case that is approved
so
agenda item eight any other items of
business the chairman of the committee
decides are Urgent I have none and
therefore I close the meeting at 9 16
according to Burnham time
thank you
thank you